you know with just a inception of
uncharted we wanted to create a playable
summer blockbuster
and everything is like you're playing
through it it's not something you're
just watching passively we're using our
meeting to the fullest
making video games as hard venture it's
hard charted it's been a perfect blend
from the actors and directors on the
mocap stage to what happens back at the
Naughty Dog Building when it works well
you hardly think about it you're just
reacting emotionally to what that
character is doing yeah can I help you
yeah I'm looking for my little brother
Sam it's good to see you Sam
oh all right now right it's not just a
big set piece as a narrative there's
character revelation there's all the
things that you want to see any kind of
cinematic moment that's happening
everything is coming together to make
you as the player feel like you're
Nathan Drake and to feel like you're on
this grand adventure I hope more than I
think you are entertained that's from
the opening shot to that final closing
image you don't want put the control
good
it's guy
you
ps4 for the players